Now, Turkey Tom's ex has just dropped a document. This is true.
She appears to have scrambled to put it together within the past
like hour, hour and a half,
and was still editing it after tweeting it. So, I'm very confused
about this one. Very confused. Turkey had some allegations dropped.
Two women came out on Kiwi Farms, started dropping allegations,
including some DMs with him.
One of those people is his most recent ex.
Uh probably the strongest allegations with the most evidence
are the ones that he is into age play. So allegations that he's
into age play, allegations that he was
aggressive, that he would be get like physical drinks in a way
that they didn't necessarily consent to, but it was gray. A lot
of it is is basically gray. One of the girls, the girl who's
his most recent ex said that when he first got physical, started
like hitting her and or choking her during that she didn't consent
to those things. They didn't have a conversation beforehand.
So, these are
I I think the other girl also had a bruise on her face and and
sent null some We'll go through that maybe in a little bit. Sent
Null some proof, right? Sent Null some proof that that may have
happened. Physical abuse in recording is a bigger deal. Oh, sure.
That's the other, sorry. The biggest allegation, I should say,
the biggest allegation by far that we just don't have evidence
of and it's very difficult to get evidence of is that he allegedly
pulls out his phone during without asking his partner and records
this encounter. Yep. Yep. That's a big one. Now, the thing you
got to know about Kai, okay, no, no, no. I've got the link to
the Google doc. The thing you got to know about Kai is that she
is,
according to lyrics, about to start pursuing a streaming career.
Pursuing a streaming career while being the person who's like
trying to cancel a big streamer. Not a good idea. Okay. My experience
with Turkey Tom
at Annon Bird. Okay. We got the tweet. So if we remember correctly,
the allegations which she could speak to. So little further information
on
on the allegations how they pertain to Kai. Within these allegations,
people have said that Tom was obsessed with his ex, that they
that she cheated on him, that which we knew, like that was already
knowledge that she was into age
right? We heard that from Aiden and we heard that from one of
the girls, I believe. Okay, so we had multiple points of of confirmation
on this. Now,
what has changed since she's What has changed from that until
today when she makes her response? Well, couple days ago, I think
it's a day and a half now, Nicholas Doro came out and said age
play was a red line for him. Yes, Nicholas Dioro, some of Turkey
Tom's friends have come out and said that age play, if this guy
engages in age play, he's basically like, I won't be around him.
So, what can we expect from this document?
Well, now the the Chud tweet kind of gave it away, but I would
expect her to sweep some of this stuff. I think I think it's
very easy for people like this to just pursue, you know, she
wants to stream. She doesn't want to be harassed by Turkey Tom
fans. Her and her boyfriend don't want to be harassed by Turkey
Tom fans. I feel like unless she had some major grievances,
she could easily opt out here. She'd easily just be g
All right. So, we're we're thinking we're prognosticating.
I've heard that this is something of a sweeping document. Okay,
so listen, this is just totally prediction, but based on her
wanting to start a streaming career, based on her,
you know, not commenting up until now, it's not shocking to me
that she would
come out and basically say that no, I don't think this is necessarily
true.
I also feel like, man, I do wonder if if Tom wasn't doing stuff
that he I feel like he treated her a lot differently. I feel
like this was the girl he treated like in his mind he treated
a lot differently and then he got cheated on. And I wouldn't
be shocked if he was like, "Oh, women are I'm going to start
treating them like that." And then went on a whole thing. Okay.
I don't know. When she says, "Oh, our wasn't like physical."
If she says something like that, I don't know how seriously I
take that. Okay. All right.
Without further ado, let's take a look.
Now, the funny thing is is Kai posted this 43 minutes ago and
then as of like 15 minutes ago, she was also looking through
the document and editing and adding. Very strange. Why was this
only a problem for these women after they broke up?
Um, I don't know if it's only a problem with them after they
woke broke up. I think what tends to happen in situations like
this, it seems like Sinatra is they think, "Oh, this behavior
was like a one-off, right? It's a one-off." and whatever it's
a one-off and you know I was and then they hear about other women
coming out discussing the exact same behaviors and they feel
like oh this is actually a pattern this is actually a problem
for me right and they go oh I'll add some credence to this other
story
you understand that how that would be like you know somebody
you get into like a dubious you get into like a dubious situation
with somebody and you kind of suspect that they have negative
intentions or they're doing something bad but you don't know
and then you find out about eight other people who went through
the exact same situation that sort of it locks a whole bunch
of things together for you, right? Like immediately you sort
of unlock and put some pieces together and they're like, "Oh,
right." You know what I'm saying? You know what I'm like? You
know what I'm saying?
Well, we only have these three photos. You can look at the photos
and then I'll I'll probably go dark mode. We can just read in
dark mode. Okay. But I I didn't even read your whole thing. Why
do any Why do the any of these women have multiple experiences
with him doing this? If it was an issue, it should should have
been an issue the first time and they should have just left.
No. Oh, also Sinatra, the other thing is is like people will
excuse things in a new relationship that aren't good.
yeah, I don't know. For for a lot of the stuff, for the physical
abuse stuff, for the not physical, like the the
like violence stuff, I do think there's a chance that that's
not really like something that he would do non-consensually.
That like that if somebody said no, he would like be totally
respectful of no. There's a good chance of that. And this is
just his total inexperience with like boundaries and [__]
Anyway, we'll we'll read. My name is Caitlyn/Kai
and I dated Turkey Tom on and off between August 2020 and November
2023, ages 17 to 20 and 21 20/2 for about 3 years total. Here
are a couple pictures of us together. And I don't think that
I don't think I've previously posted, but regardless, you can
see we are the same person based on this recent photo of me.
Okay, this is something I really thought I would never have to
respond to. I have spent over 2 years going out of my way to
avoid addressing any of the claims made about me or my relationship.
I have privated all social media for a very long time because
I've never wanted to be a spectacle for people to poke at intimate
uh be a spectacle for people to poke at intimate details of my
life for their own entertainment. Given recent events, however,
I feel a sense of responsibility to say something. Tom and I
had a very mutually toxic relationship, and yes, we both cheated
on each other online.
This behavior isn't good for either of us, but we but are private
matters that don't in any way deserve to be blasted on the internet
by me, and I would never feel like I would never feel the need
to put that out to the world by my own choice. Unfortunately,
it's being made public against either of our wishes. So, I thought
I should just acknowledge it. Now, to give my experience with
Tom in relation to these serious allegations being made by former
partners, there's a lot of information being shared that I find
to be extremely unnecessary with the driving motivator to humiliate
him.
I think that's true. I think this is broadly true from what I'm
seeing,
right? I I I do think like there's a a lot of it is seemingly
to humiliate, at least from the Clorox Katy person. The Clorox
Katy person seems pretty intent on humiliation. The other girl
seems like she was upset and
when she reached out to somebody, that person validated a lot
of her fears and so she felt like this guy was scum and less
than humiliation. He was just like a little bit getting even
a little bit warning people.
Anyway, continue. I found this behavior to be abhorentt and will
not address any minor anecdote about him.
Okay,
minor anecdote. Minor anecdote. I'm sorry about him that doesn't
carry emotional relevance. I really need to stress that this
is just my experience and he may have acted differently with
other girls who was he was involved with after me. I'm not undermining
anyone's experiences and don't wish to speculate on their credibility.
I will directly reply to him as a partner overall at the end.
In regards to recording encounters, the few times we did record
anything, it was either with explicit permission beforehand or
an established consent based on previous conversations in our
long-term relationship. It really wasn't a frequent thing that
happened, mostly before we started living together and were long
distance.
There are a lot of stuff we did where I look back and shake my
head because my standards for myself really have changed so much
since then, but everything was always consensual between us.
There were a few instances where I became uncomfortable with
an encounter and he was understanding and would not continue
after I voiced his comfort.
Um, I do think this seems to be backed up by the text themselves
that somebody tells him like, "Hey, I don't like this." And he's
like, "Oh, we don't have to do that." Right? He's like, "Oh,"
she's like, "We don't have to have like rough multiple times
a day." And he's like, "Yeah, we can do less."
I don't know. It It seemed like I've seen no evidence that he
was like manipulative or coercive.
You know what I mean? Now, that doesn't mean there's nothing
going on there, but
I don't think this is an allegation being made about him, but
I wanted to stress that nothing in the bedroom that was rough
or aggressive ever translated to domestic interactions. There
are a lot of negative things to say about Tom, but he always
he was always surprisingly patient and never did so much as yell
at me.
I never once felt fearful of him when he was angry. And the entire
time we were in a relationship which included living together
for six months. Oh, in the entire time we were in a relationship
which included living together for six months. There's been a
message circulating claiming that Tom and I participated in age
play which is just a blatant twisting of the truth. Tom definitely
romanticizes power dynamics and heavy dom sub stuff, but that
was never expressed through age related dynamics uh age related
dynamic role playinging. It's clearly as a type for Sanrio mentally
ill e girls, but I can't I just can't say from my experience
that it was ever in nature. The person I knew between the years
of 2020 to 2023 was not into those things. Anything after that,
I wouldn't know.
It's true that Tom has a blackmail folder on me consisting of
phone recordings and text messages. I've known about it for a
very long time because he told me we were messy as okay. We were
messy as okay. I never had any intentions of speaking about him
publicly, but I did decide to be evil after one of the times
we broke up and tell him I was going to ruin his career because
he was ignoring me and I knew it would freak him out. So, like,
yeah, I get this his concern, even though I've clarified a million
times that I would never do that. This was extremely to me and
I'm really embarrassed to admit it publicly, but without this
context, it looks worse than it is. I do not feel Oh man, that's
a heavy sweep. That is a heavy sweep. But I do think I understand
that. And that that jibes with everything I know. That jives
with everything I know. I do think that is a a lot right there.
Right. Right. That's like
Listen, I know he's a blackmail folder on me, but I I did kind
of deserve it. I did kind of actually totally deserve it. >> Turkey
Tom is a great man. Every anecdote about him is great. Even the
minor ones, just ladder than your minor
>> Thank you so much for the donation. Appreciate it. Well,
I think she's she's almost certainly
Maximus. She's probably in the middle of drama- hungry nutters
and Tom wanting to to stay quiet.
Yes. And like her boyfriend is a former drama streamer who's
gone into like a music streaming thing and he wants to get away
from like the heavier online drama as
So, between the two of them, I definitely understand why they
don't want this to go any further.
I get it.
Uh, but I like this also this doesn't seem like a lie to me.
You know what I mean? Like this. It's different. I I say it's
a heavy sweep because it's like something I wouldn't expect you
to really like say outright,
but it doesn't seem like something like I'm not looking at this
and going, "Oh, I can definitely tell otherwise." Lots of times
when when stuff like when something like this is said, I can
point to facts of what we know and say, "Oh, that seems to be
like totally it flies in the face of what I actually know." With
this one, it actually seems to jive with everything we do know
about the
and like how messy it got.
It spilled into public like in a very tiny few times. Okay. Just
like twice maybe
cuz her current boyfriend
a few different times opened his DMs live on a stream and showed
that he was still talking to her. Like like right uh so I think
right when Tom and her took a break, he leaked his DMs showing
that he was talking to her. And then another time after her and
Tom had gotten back together, he also leaked his DMs showing
that he was still talking to her. Very
You wonder how accidental that could possibly be. It doesn't
seem very accidental when you think about it, but
Okay. So, I do not feel at all fearful about him leaking anything
private relating to me in response to this because I think I've
been very respectful along with everything being the truth. Overall,
Tom as a person is extremely flawed and I'm disappointed to see
he is still generally self-centered around and acts.
Dude,
uh
I'm still keeping the dry. Not not a fan of that, guys. Listen,
as as his first long-term partner, not a fan that he still can't
get a wet, okay? Not happy to hear it. Tragic tragic to hear
this, okay? To be dry around Tom, okay? It's up as up. It's [__]
up.
Our relationship really me up for a while, and certain things
still affect me negatively from it. According to what some have
said, it goes both ways. Most of the things that hurt me about
our relationship don't have much crossover with what what other
people have said about him. So, I feel relieved that I can still
maintain some privacy in a sense. We literally met as minors,
and it's still the longest relationship I've been in. You don't
date someone for 3 plus years if you think they are an irredeemable
piece of [__] I've never known him to be a person
capable of these things. But everyone who has spoken about him
has been after we broke up. So, I just couldn't know. As sad
and angry as he's made me feel, I've never thought him to be
heartless or sadistically cruel. Just someone that has a lot
of issues. All I have is my own experience to use as my guide
for what I think is true. But others shouldn't take it as gospel
above anyone anyone sorry above someone else's
I apologize for my brevity as I only want to give pointed answers
to avoid relaying intimate details about my life with an ex.
I do not want to come across like I'm exposing Turkey Tom.
I listen I didn't read the document. I just I heard a document
dropped. I went live. So, if I misled you guys that she was sort
of exposing Turkey Tom, I don't apologize, okay? It's clickbait.
Deal with it. Deal with it. [__] you. You're here
now. Okay? You're here now. You're listening to it. It is what
it is, man.
It is what it is. Okay. I just felt morally inclined to share
my experience about certain things since people have been wanting
to hear specifically
since people have been wanting to specifically hear what I had
to say. I don't think there's any need for follow-up. I've said
everything I wish to comment on. I hope I can just go about my
life without this constantly coming up because we've been broken
up for so long now.
Now,
there's a couple ways you could look at this, okay? That she's
trying to be as helpful to Tom as possible,
right? Because she wants to go into streaming. She clearly didn't
want to with this guy's career,
right?
She she didn't want to [__] with this guy's career.
She wants to go into streaming. So, she's going to give him like
the best send off she can as like a, hey,
let me go. Let me do my thing. I don't want your fans harassing
me. I don't want any of that [__] I just want a clean
break here, right?
That's one way. And the other way is like, oh, this is all truthful.
I mean, I guess it could all be truthful and it be a sendoff,
right?
At the same time. I'm so curious what Tom has her blackmailed
with. Well, it sounds like her basically saying, "I'm going to
ruin your life. I'm going to do all this."
I guarantee you like based on what I've heard it sounds like
both of them threatening to self harm both of them like it's
I even confusing like I
like I could just imagine what it's like it's just it's very
obvious I think to most people if you've ever been in a toxic
relationship it's pretty obvious what that would look like right
one of these one of the women said Tom threatened to like self
harm before had talked about self harming right so yeah man yeah
man Oh, Chud post this. This is going to be the same as other
people.
He calls out Aiden specifically. Turkey Tom's ex Kai, the one
who bounced between him and Larry, has released a document about
her relationship with Tom. In it, she contests Aiden's claims
about age play. Is she sweeping or did Aiden push misinformation
to get the heat off of himself for doxing claims?
here's the here's the thing. This is what Aiden said. Dude, I'm
leaking Kais into age player told me when he first broke up with
her.
Now, Aiden said this stuff. Okay, Aiden underground. There it
is. Now, I'm hearing through the grapevine
that Quimman
called Aiden
without informing him that he was streaming and started asking
him about this stuff.
And Aiden didn't Aiden started just spilling his guts. I hope
it's okay. I'm going to head over here real quick.
I'm going to head over here real quick and see what the [__]
going on. Oh god, my phone alarm's going off. Jesus Christ. By
the way, Aiden is like on the lamb right now. I've heard I've
heard tell that Aiden is actually like missing. Aiden was staying
with a guy in Britain a day before his flight. He just took he
packed up all of his. He's gone. How did this happen?
>> what's up? >> Have you heard that Kaij has dropped
a dock on Tom?
Are you [__] Are you kidding me? >> Uh, no.
It It says nothing. It basically it seems like the only reason
she's put this out is to deny the age play allegations. So, what
say you?
>> Well, Lyric tried to call me about this a few days ago
and I didn't pick up cuz I was preoccupied. But >> I think
that should happen on stream. I think that that conversation
should be >> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. For sure. For sure. Um,
I think that Yeah. when I come back, he's I'll be back in like
what uh is it two days? Like two days or something like awesome.
basically uh yeah, I'll let him call. I told you this. I when
I at the time I told No, I didn't tell you this. I told Shelby
this and I told someone else this. I can't remember.
>> Yeah. And then and then they told you. But at the time
that I did,
Dude,
Aiden, if you did, if you missed that, Aiden basically said,
"As soon as this guy told me a secret, I told you and another
person. I told you know how I as soon as this guy told me a secret,
I told you and another person." You know how that happened? >> There
was no There was no drama involved. Do you want to just like
relay in the most accurate and full detail possible exactly what
Lar told you when >> um like circumstances, context,
>> So, okay. Okay. Yeah. So, I I I don't have the exact
It was actually it would have been around the I guess era of
my streaming when I had first spoken to you about like Evan does.
>> Okay. Uh I'm hearing actually that Queen said in the
DM, I want to call you talk come talk on stream about this, right?
And then Aiden
didn't read that message.
Okay. >> Things or whatever the [__] it
>> three years ago or something roughly. >> Yeah.
It was like two. Yeah. Yeah. Like two years. It doesn't matter.
But like it was lyric uh lyrics at this point. I don't know if
he had basically him and Kai were like doing together uh obviously
as we know uh while he was with Tom and then
uh and then basically
um at some point I guess they had broken it off or I don't remember
me and Lyrics were good friends at that point and we were in
a call and I do not remember why this came up but I remember
at this point this was when the affair was like first not fair.
The uh cheating and [__] was first being publicized
cuz we had people like uh Zany or whatever his name was and Salvo
coming out with all this
>> That that was when lyrics leaked to Jaylen and then
Jaylen leaked to Salvo or whatever, right? >> Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah, I think so. Once again, my memory is like very vague on
this like general time period, so I may don't take like everything
like completely literally. I might get some uh general [__]
wrong, but the overall premise is the same. I'd spoken to lyrics
at this time about the with Tom, whatever. Uh, and he was telling
me, I guess he was mad at Kai at that point in time or something
in that regard. And he was he had told me in a call. I remember
I was just playing Call of Duty, but he had said that like Kai
likes to something about her. She likes to pretend to be like
a little girl uh during with Tom. Like that's the she's into
um and that yeah, that was like that whole conversation. And
I've just been like sitting on that. >> He just said it
as an off-handed comment or did you ask any more? >> It
was not. It was not. We were having a conver we were having a
conversation about the general subject of him, Tom, and Kai.
Um, but I don't remember like I don't remember anything but that
de like
>> Oh boy. Aiden, I don't remember that
>> Oh boy. >> Yeah. How how young does she pretend
to be? Is it like 15, 12, six? Ask for details. I I I remember
just like the term like little like girl or kid or something.
So I'm assuming
>> yeah I'm assuming it's younger than
>> but that's that's that's literally like that's all I
know about it. The only thing I can't prove it or anything. Obviously
my memor is vague. The only thing that would
>> also I'm going to have a bone to pick with this Aiden
guy. Okay. Apparently now the next day HE'S GOING ON STREAMS
Is this about I get I He promises to come on last night and then
he goes, "Oh, wait. No, I'm not going to go on streams anymore."
Oh, hold on. Look at this guy real quick. Real quick. Cuz he
actually gave me permission to show this. Look at this. Look
at this piece of Hold on. Hold on. I'm actually I'm actually
not showing I'm actually not showing this other my own part.
Hold on. I need to I need to
saying this when at a time when it wouldn't have had any benefit
to me. Um, >> do do you think there's any chance that maybe
Lex was being vindictive and trying to spin back the allegations
against Tom?
>> Sorry, you cut out. Can you say that one more time?
>> Do you think there's any chance Lar was being vindictive
and trying to spin back the allegations against Tom? What What
was the tone of that conversation? Was he being like, >> was
it sort of like, okay, was Larry like seething? Was this like
pissed off? Was that about them? Is that what was happening in
this conversation? If I remember, I don't want to answer that
with certainty because I could be up, but that's the vibe that
I I'm pretty sure was going on. Yes. >> Got you.
Got you. So, do you remember anything else about the conversation?
Any other leaks you can give from that from that
>> No. No. Nothing. There's things that like I kind There's
things that I like vaguely I feel like I vaguely remember something
about like play, but like I that could have just been like a
like and all. The only thing I'm sure of was the age play stuff.
The other like might just be like cuz I've heard it before. I'm
now just like merging it with the memory or whatever.
>> We'll go over we'll check out the sticker stuff right
after this. We'll we'll keep it tight in a segment.
>> age play. Age play. >> Yeah. I don't know if there's
anything else you'd you'd know about in this
Oh, yeah. Apparently, uh, so Aiden, you you always hint about
Kai like trying to come on to you when you met her, right? >> What?
I've never heard this.
>> don't run. >> What the [__] >> dude?
Why is he Why is he cutting it? >> He's running. He's running.
>> I'm not. No. >> Going through a tunnel. >> I'm
not running.
>> I'm in I'm in the room with >> Hey, Aiden, you
always said this [__] was hitting on you. Is this
true? OH, NO. YOU'RE CUTTING OUT. NO. HERE. I
>> You always You always uh hint at Kai like making advances
towards you. What's all that about?
>> I didn't I We just had this like really strange interaction.
Uh but just You're Are you live? >> I'm live. Yeah.
>> Okay. Okay.
Um well, anyways.
>> you knew I was live, right? Surely >> I I I probably
should I I >> messaged you. I messaged you. I said, "Are
you free to call out?"
>> No, it's fine. No, no, I'm fine. I'm fine saying everything
that I said to you live. I I I wouldn't have said the I wouldn't
have said the >> No, he's not like rape play.
>> No, he's not. No, he's not. Oh, it was rape play. Okay.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Which I mean, obviously >> because I'm
not sure.
>> Listen, Tom, a man of Patrician Taste in that in that
case >> because I'm not sure of that and I wouldn't want
to start like a rumor about that. What? >> Um, but >> draw
strike the right play [__] from the record. Strike
the right play [__] from the record. That's not Yeah,
>> it's not public. >> Anything that I'm not certain.
Anything that I'm not certain. Um, I'm just just don't don't
use that if I'm not certain cuz once again, this is memory from
your >> I will I will not be striking that. I will not
be striking that. That will not be stricken for the record. That
will stay on the record actually.
>> but yeah, there's there's nothing else that
um >> what was the Sorry, what was the the last thing we
were just talking about? I don't remember what um Oh, yeah. Kai
coming on to you. Kai making advances towards you. That was it.
>> Yeah. I There was something that I interpreted as like
a bit strange, but I kind of saw her being met with like everyone.
It was like Tom went upstairs and then she's like, "Look at like
my eyes or whatever." And I was and she's like, "You have the
darkest eyes I've ever seen. Like it's so cool." Or it was I
felt like a little strange, but I wasn't cuz he was like upstairs
or whatever. Uh but like I maybe I guess that's just like how
she is. She was like announcing to like a a room of like or it
was like a car full of people that she had like BPD and stuff
and I was like dude
>> and what about these uh there there's rumors swirling
of Turkey Tom having a addiction. Do you think there's any way
>> I've seen him do Listen, I've seen or I haven't seen
him actually do the
>> you have oncreen chat anymore. Um cuz they can't have
it on screen for most platforms. they don't like the mixing or
they just don't like slurs that come through and so I've kept
it off stream. I can have it on stream for
when I'm on kick only which I am right now but I'm I'm back on
Twitch tomorrow come off from Coke. Um
but like other people were trying Coke. I don't I've I don't
I've seen no evidence of an addiction. I've just I just know
that he's like dabbled in it or tried it occasionally. >> Wow.
Terrible stuff. Really terrible >> True. Agre egregious.
>> He shouldn't be doing that. Terrible
>> Yeah. All right. Well, is I I don't like I'm cur like
I haven't seen anything. Once again, I I'm going to sit through
and properly look through this, but is there anything like
I guess that he cuz all this like what it sounds all this sounds
just incredibly like emarrassing and weird. >> Yeah, that's
most of it. >> But like Yeah. Is that it? It's just like
embarrassing and weird. >> Yeah. Just the big question
is about the age play stuff right now because um everyone has
decided that age play is their red line for association with
Tom for some reason. So all the discussion is is he an age player?
>> Wait, don't get me wrong. I think age
>> That is where the entire conversation is right now is
how much of this is the age play? disgusting and and adjacent
too, but that's not really like if it's happening between two
consenting adults in in a private bedroom like I >> it's
blind to draw especially for a friend you've had for like a decade.
It's a totally it's clearly just because they've worked themselves
into stupid positions about you know age play and and whatever
the so they have to save >> Yeah, fair enough. All right,
well have a good stream. Take care. Catch you